en la firma de este acuerdo conjunto
estuvieron presentes Antonio García el
máximo comandante del Ln y alias Pablo
Beltrán y por parte del gobierno
colombiano el alto comisionado para la
paz Danilo Rueda y el senador Iván
Cepeda se firmó acá mis espaldas en la
antigua sede presidencial de la casona
sobre cuándo se va a reanudar este
proceso de diálogo dijeron que era para
la segunda semana de Noviembre sin
embargo no especificaron fecha tampoco
sede aseguraron que se va a continuar
con lo que se ve acordado bajo el
gobierno de Juan Manuel Santos en 2016
de que la sede fuera rotativa entre los
países garantes Venezuela Noruega y Cuba
sin embargo no quisieron especificar
dónde sería esa reunión consultados
además sobre si una de las condiciones
sería el cese al fuego y la liberación
de Rehenes el máximo comandante del Ln
dijo que si el problema era las armas el
cese de las armas ya estuviese
solucionado Que para él ese no era la
principal preocupación sino solucionar
los problemas de fondo que originaron el
conflicto respondieron las preguntas a
la prensa por separado o hubo bastante
hermetismo bastante control a los medios
de comunicación en este pronunciamiento
y trataron de no ofrecer mayores
detalles que lo he leído en el
comunicado también estuvieron presentes
representantes de la misión de
verificación de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas y también por parte del
gobierno venezolano Cuba y Noruega
países grandes